[Music]
ron swanson's office
yes
i will transfer
you just dropped another call
this came out
yeah
i am starving i haven't had lunch since
yesterday so i'm gonna head over to
callahan's oh no no don't go there they
totally skimp on pickles let me go to
bighead joes for you they have the most
insane burritos i don't much go for
ethnic food
trust me they have one that's called the
meat tornado
literally killed a guy last year you had
me at meat tornado
beer garcon
was a six round pick
kali was the fourth round indianapolis
colts
know how to draft so well they really do
andy this was delicious
it's awesome huh
it's a whole new meat delivery system
thank you son what do you say we go out
to the parking lot run a few pass plays
to burn off the calories you are an
unstoppable good idea machine
i like andy
i'm surrounded by a lot of women in this
department
and that includes the men
peyton manning reading the defense
reggie wait
paul's corner
[Laughter]
libertarianism is all about individual
liberty and it should never be defined
by the terms liberal or conservative and
communism is no good that's right big
swing and a miss yeah and what's the
word for when a few clerics are in
charge
religious oligarchy holy
i can remember things
i guess
[Music]
hey keep mine rare a man after my own
heart
april where have you been over two phone
calls came in unimpeded we're raising
money for my college education ron
i took a second job back at my old job
do you want a shoe shine it's a hundred
dollars
laugh all you want kyle i already took
the money out of your wallet
oh
good news son
you have just won
a ron swanson scholarship
i don't think so i don't remember
applying for anything andy ron swanson
scholarship
wait are you serious
stop this no
i stop or you lose the money
why not
i like the kid and i have the money
one thing i promised myself when i
buried gold in my backyard was that i'd
never be a hoarder or a miser about it
first day
you ready as ready as i'll ever be
oh crap i forgot my books and my
computer just pay attention to the
lecture and enjoy my first day of
college my father dropped me off
at the steel mill
he didn't think i should go to college
but i hitched a ride and rolled and
learned a lot
hope andy does too
lemonade
please and thank you hey i'm sorry if i
was kurt earlier
i'm a single mom and sometimes things
get chaotic around here when you showed
up from the parks department no need to
apologize i understand completely
this is delicious well i got it from
food and stuff so that's where i got
these gloves right
so
how exactly are you gonna fix this hole
just for my own edification
uh i dug the loose gravel out of the
hole now i'm using a jackhammer to
remove the larger pieces then i'll spray
down the hole to settle the dust
and fill it with cold patch asphalt
well thank you
now i can fix the next one myself
ron and diane sitting in a tree
k-i-s-s-i-s-s-i-p-p-i
do you hear that bird lie the mother on
her side and try to move the baby in a
corkscrew fashion diane is awesome and
she likes you and you like her i can
tell a i don't recall inviting you in
here and b i did not like her she's not
my type her life is messy
messy is fun okay my whole life is a
giant mess and i love it i mean look at
my hair i have gum in my hair
listen i will not pursue diane end of
story
hmm if you're here to complain about the
pothole i guarantee i did it correctly
actually i'm here to ask you out for
dinner
really
well i hope you're not the kind of man
who needs to ask the lady out i'm a
middle school vice principal i don't
screw around does that freak you out
no on the contrary
so dinner
please and thank you
well it'll be casual no need to wear
makeup
i begrudgingly admit that the 3-1-1
program is a moderate success
i'm still not sure why the citizen
decided to come speak with me in person
but i'm just happy to see a government
program finally work
i never thought i'd say this to you
son
but you may be overthinking this
the song has to be perfect ron
okay leslie trusted me with it i can't
come up with some brilliant political
idea can i
this is the only way i can help
maybe if i hit my head against ground
that's worked before leslie is gonna
love it i promise
no offense ron but what do you know
about music
hey take a walk
clear your head
i bet it does you some good
all right guys here's the deal
we got to completely start over i wrote
a new song it's called the promise of
tomorrow's wings it's brilliant about a
billion times better than catch your
dreams which i realize now sucks ass hey
chuck go ahead and just uh delete
everything all right hold on chuck just
listen to the song one more time and
then make a decision
where's that saxophone coming from i
don't know i don't know the first thing
about music
oh is that a new mix sounds way better
see just needed to clear your head
hey you guys who is this this looks just
like
wow that was loud
[Music]
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to also i had a
banana on the way over here
sorry
i get why you don't want anyone to know
about duke silver and you don't have to
worry
your secret is safe with me
to even it out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's not necessary i once forgot to
brush my teeth for five weeks i didn't
actually sell my last car i just forgot
where i parked it i don't know who al
gore is and at this point i'm too afraid
to ask when they say two percent milk i
don't know what the other 98 is when i
was a baby my head was so big scientists
did experiments on me i once threw a
beer to swan and then it attacked my
niece rebecca that'll do andrew
you don't have to play the unity concert
but don't quit music
please
hey ron
can i ask you kind of an important
question
you know like when you go to the atm
and you get money is there an actual guy
standing behind the wall who slides
dollar bills in there
no yeah
this is robots oh actually you know what
i do have a serious question in a movie
predator
can you rub any kind of mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
this thermal heat signature site or is
it one ow
that sucks are you hurt
oh no all good
all good
oops except for my mouth
oh whoa
five second rule
no
ah come on we better get you to a
dentist
if you're all right i'm gonna head back
to the park
liquid do you know what my social
security number is or if i'm allergic to
anything i don't like corn should i put
that down or will that be confusing
because i do like candy corn
oh
ron what a mess
here let me help you all i wanted was
two hours where i got to forget that i
was a parent oh look i found all three
differences those are two completely
different pictures
you